first of all thank you for inviting us
all to the Renaissance we appreciate
that it's
an amazing time I can imagine in your
life
that an outpouring of love coming your
way like all the time now thank you
um what can I say I'm touched uh
grateful yeah from one big heart to mine
too I I send it right back yeah and I
hope to come see the whale because
that's what this is about
[Music]
forget the feeling people are incapable
of not carrying does it feel different
like this point in your life this time
in your life does it feel different can
you receive it differently I mean you
know once we've lived a little bit of
life you know I'm serious we receive
things differently you know our kids now
you know and that really weren't how I
make decisions about what I'm gonna do
and then whatever it is that I'm doing
about how I feel about what I'm doing
and somehow the stakes get raised to
such a point that something that may
seem Garden variety or normal takes on
much more gravity and I I think as
actors and and writers and creators we
have to find these uh Inspirations and
tools that move us that that you know
really give us a reason to do what we do
and it's nice work if you can get it
let's let's be honest here and and every
now and then a piece comes along if
you're lucky that that you find that you
connect with in a way it makes you care
more and and this is one of those films
I was a little bit if I'm being honest a
little like skeptical going in because I
had seen all the video all the love all
the outpouring and I'm thinking can this
really like really sit with people like
this damn straight it can like I I no
joke I mean my mother was obese for the
longest time you know growing up so I
think I really connected personally to
it and I know you you know riding it you
were actually kind of drawing from your
experience in college as well yeah I was
yeah I mean I nothing in the play is
directly autobiographical but it does
stem from a lot of personal details that
that before writing this play I'd really
not accessed in my writing or maybe even
in my life either I mean in that way the
the writing the play kind of felt like
an act of Auto fiction and active
self-therapy
um and I'm just so glad that I was able
to give it to somebody like Brendan
um it was such a kind and generous soul
and also
brilliant
oh you're getting your flowers today man
just sit here and take it it's gone
it's happening it's happening I actually
called my mom after watching this food
because now because Charlie is so
vulnerable in a lot of ways but so
hidden in a lot of ways and I guess you
don't even really necessarily know that
I mean like I said with just being in
her life for so long sometimes you you
don't even think about what the inner
scars can be and what what that can
happen and I love when I saw that you
said you really connect to Charlie's
inner scars and I just how so can you
elaborate on that a little bit Charlie's
life is one that's lived behind closed
doors and it's a story that really plays
out all across the nation in the world
and we don't often know what that is
so when we're invited into
his world his two-bedroom apartment in
somewhere Idaho
and his existence which has come to a
place where sadly he's been harming
himself for his broken heart and
that's been through overeating a
combination of depression a whole host
of reasons it doesn't really matter it's
just the point is if he's a person he's
a man and he's so much more than who he
would appear to be to the world and it's
so easy to be cynical and dismiss
others that way when we know the
challenge of connecting with those is
what brings us closes together is time
is limited he wants very much to connect
with his daughter
um and
because it's the tension of the story is
there that we're not always certain if
he can or if he's going to make it Sadie
sink played her role with such a
ferocious issue gorgeous sadness and
beautiful rage that never falls into the
Trope of the angsty teenager and what we
wind up seeing is this is a little girl
who was hurt badly by her father and she
has every reason to be crossed with him
to be polite Hong Chao as his friend his
counselor's caregiver his he puts her in
the awkward position of being an enabler
of sorts yeah to him yeah she is I mean
you see it she's bringing him intensely
controls are going to harm she's a medic
she's a nurse right she cares for him he
is the last connection to her late
brother their relationship is is complex
and fraught and and when we meet them
but you can
Hong has a manner of making everything
better and everyone better with what she
does I'll say it a thousand times again
she can say more in the pauses and the
silences in between lines then I think
what she speaks from what she's read of
a screenplay in better days in a
different life earlier they would have
been hilarious at a dinner party or
playing Pictionary or something like
that but this is not that time when we
meet them by the way the chemistry with
the two of you on screen Sam
I asked her I'm like had you all did you
know each other she said no we just met
them like that is wild because you
cannot fake that I know y'all are good
actors but you're not that good of
actors to say like the chemistry between
y'all was it was palpable it really was
you talk about the father and daughter
aspect of this film um which of course
is like the the through theme your daddy
now you were saying like how did that
sit with you when you were looking at
the relationship with a with a father
and daughter did it inspire you anymore
to maybe think a little deeper about
what you know your kids are saying
absolutely I mean and I I I spent the
first I don't know what 25 years of my
career or so making films that
I I generated all the hope and
aspiration and and and Joy from what I
believe to be
coming from a character or a screenplay
and then some alchemy happens when you
have kids and suddenly everything clicks
as he well knows his daughters and his
life as a little girl now and we we put
such extra meaning and and understanding
to what maybe just you know very Garden
variety or normal for us but it somehow
raises the stakes and um
and and uh somehow for me at least
increases the authenticity of what we do
Hong said that you guys did rehearsals
for a while for this three weeks and
there was something that happened they
said there was some light that that went
off something did you see this too do
you know what it was because they said
they have no idea but something switched
and you something flipped in you and it
just like this brilliant Beauty wildness
came out that's kind but that's the
reason why you rehearse you know you
make all your mistakes first before you
step in front of the camera to hopefully
not make them and to have three weeks to
do this is incredibly generous amount of
time to make a film and I think you're
only as good as people you're working
with so whatever that was I'm grateful
to hear it from you but I'm sure it came
from paying attention to what they were
doing and getting out of my head or away
from the book as best I could
[Music]
thank you